although we have made huge progress with
science and with physics there are still
a lot of things we don't understand we
don't have that t-shirt yet with
equations everything for example we have
you can make a t-shirt with Einstein's
theory of gravity and you can make
another which describes all big things
really excellently and you can make
another t-shirt with the equations of
quantum mechanics which describe the
subatomic world really great but those
two teachers don't get along
there is another teacher that nobody has
figured out exactly what should be on it
yet there may be a string theory maybe
something else so some humility is in
order but it's quite striking how much
progress we've made you know 400 years
ago yes like when Galileo famously said
that our universe is the grand book
within the language of mathematics yes
the almost the only thing you could do
with math then it was predictive physics
of motion yes if Galileo could predict
that if you throw a hazelnut and a grape
but they would both move in the shape
called the parabola y equals x squared
simple math shape right but Galileo
would have no idea why the grape was
green and the hazelnut was brown while
the grape was soft and the hizmet was
hard the Maxwell came with other
equations for light and stuff that
explained colors and then we got quantum
mechanics which explained why some
things are hard and others are soft and
if you look now we've actually gradually
managed to describe almost we've gone
from describing almost nothing except
motion with math to describing almost
everything with math and what mainly
remains are some issues about what's
happening inside of black holes what
happened yes very very long ago and
around the time we were BIGBANG Altimas
future of our universe and most
flagrantly what's actually happening in
our heads yeah the science of
intelligence taken off quite a bit with
AI and but we certainly have a long way
to go and the most spectacular failure
if it field so far is our ability to
just write down an actual scientific
theory of consciousness why is it that
we have these subjective
experiences of colors and sounds and so
on rather than just feel like zombies we
go through the motions but it doesn't
feel like anything to be us I'm I think
some people dismiss this is just silly
pointless philosophy I see it
differently I feel that we are just
being lame and making excuses for not
actually solving this science problem I
think both consciousness and
intelligence or all about information
processing and-and-and sorry I don't
think it matters ultimately whether the
information is processed by carbon atoms
inside of neurons inside of brains or by
silicon atoms in our technology but I
and what I do think matters is well
there is some kind so many other
equations which tell you which kinds of
information processing are conscious and
which aren't and we just haven't
discovered them and we should